>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR OUR
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE
EXPOSE WHAT'S REALLY BEHIND THE
BIG CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
CNN MAY HAVE TO ISSUE A MAJOR
ATTRACTION AFTER THEY CHARGED
MORGAN FREEMAN WITH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND WOULD YOU PAY MORE THAN A
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A T-SHIRT?
NO.
HERE TO EXPLAIN IT IS AUTHOR OF
A BEST-SELLING SERIES, RAYMOND
ARROYO.
SO MORGAN FREEMAN IS AN
ACADEMY AWARD WINNER.
SHE WROTE A PIECE EXPOSING AND
CHARGING MORGAN FREEMAN WITH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SHE CLAIMED SHE WAS ON A JUNKET
INTERVIEWING FREEMAN AND IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE INTERVIEW, HE
LOOKED OVER AND SAID, OH, I WISH
I WERE THERE.
AND LOOK TOWARD HER.
SHE WAS PREGNANT AT THE TIME AND
SHE TOOK THAT AS
AND HE SAID HE WAS TALKING TO
MICHAEL CAINE WHO TALKED ABOUT
GOING TO SOME LOCALE.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH THE
ENTIRE REPORT.
WHY ARE THEY ALLOWED TO WRITE
THE PIECE BY CNN?
AND, THIS IS A ME TOO MOVEMENT
WHICH IS EXPOSING SOME REAL
ABUSES, BUT THIS -- WHEN YOU SAY
SOMETHING LIKE, YOU ARE LOOKING
AT ME, IT'S LIKE KIDS SAYING,
MARIA IS LOOKING AT ME, STOP
LOOKING AT ME.
THEN TEN YEARS LATER IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE HUGS AND ALL THAT.
>> FREEMAN IS NOW SAYING THROUGH
HIS LAWYER, THIS IS DEFAMATION,
AND IN THIS AGE OF WHEN YOU HAVE
A BLACK CELEBRITY LIKE THIS AT
THIS LEVEL, I THINK AND CNN HAS.
>> Laura: NOW ROSEANNE, THE
PROBLEM IS THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
A TOXIC PRESIDENT WHO AMASSED
HIS POWER THROUGH PROVOCATION OF
HATE.
AND THE TRUMP SUPPORTER
NORMALIZES RACISM AND MISOGYNY,
AND OF COURSE THROW IT IN FOR
GOOD MEASURE, SEEN A PHOBIA.
SO HAVING A CHARACTER ON THE
SHOW WHO SUPPORTS TRUMP, IS
RACISM AND MISOGYNY?
>> WE ARE'S SEEING BLANKET
RACISM BEING THROWN AROUND, AND
PEOPLE ARE CONFUSING
ROSEANNE BARR THE ACTOR AND
ROSEANN CONNOR WHO PLAYS ROSEANN
ON TV.
ROSEANN DID ITS JOB.
IT AWAKENED AT THE ENTERTAINMENT
COMMUNITY.
IT WAS OF MIDDLE AMERICA,
UNDERSERVED AND THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR SOMEONE TO BE THEIR
VOICE TO.
WE WILL SEE IT IN OTHER
CHARACTERS, SO WATCH.
>> Laura: THERE IS TOO MUCH
MONEY TO BE MADE TO.
AND GIVING A VOICE TO SOMEONE
WHO IS NOT DEMONIZED EVERY FIVE
SECONDS.
THEY ARE STILL DEMONIZING THE
TRUMP SUPPORT AS            ANDS
TRUMP SUPPORT AS            ANDP
TRUMP SUPPORT AS            ANDO
TRUMP SUPPORT AS            ANDT
TRUMP SUPPORT AS            ANDR
TRUMP SUPPORT AS            AND.
NOW, JESSE DUPLANTIS, I HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF HIM.
>> HE'S FROM MY NECK OF THE
WORDS IN LOUISIANA.
>> Laura: IS A WHAT IS HE
SAYING?
>> HE SAYS THE LORD HAS CALLED
HIM TO HAVE ANOTHER PRIVATE JET.
>> YOU KNOW, HE SAID I CAN DO IT
FROM ONE SPOT.
I BELIEVE IF JESUS WAS
PHYSICALLY ON THE EARTH TODAY,
HE WOULDN'T BE RIDING A DONKEY.
>> WHEN THE LORD SAID SORT OF
YOUR RICHES IN HEAVEN, I DON'T
THINK THIS IS WHAT HE HAD IN
THIS GUY IS ASKING $54 MILLION
FROM HIS FOLLOWERS FOR A FOURTH
PRIVATE JET.
>> Laura: WOULD IT BE G4?
>> KENNETH COPELAND ALSO HAD A
PRIVATE PLANES, AND THEY ARE ON
TV, DEFENDING WHY THEY NEED
PRIVATE PLANES.
>> WHAT'S THAT THING ABOUT
GETTING A RICH PERSON?
>> WATCH.
WE CAN'T GET HERE WITHOUT THIS,
WE GOT TO HAVE THIS.
I WOULD HAVE TO STOP.
I'M BEING VERY CONSERVATIVE, AT
LEAST 75-80, MORE LIKE 90% OF
WHAT WE ARE DOING.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET THEM HERE.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
>> THEY DON'T LIKE COMMERCIAL
AIRLINES, AND, I WILL LEAVE IT
HERE.
>> LAYOUT $1,290 T-SHIRT SHIRT
HAS BEEN RELEASED.
THIS IS IT.
YOU CAN SPEND $1,000 TO
ESSENTIALLY LOOK LIKE A LAUNDRY
RACK.
IT IS A BUTTON UP SHIRT SEWN
ONTO YOUR T-SHIRT, OR YOU CAN
WEAR IT INTERCHANGEABLY AND HAVE
A T-SHIRT.
>> OR YOU COULD GO BACK AND GET
MY OLD STICK SEWING MACHINE OUT.
>> I'M NOT BUYING.